cool
so action australia
my name is vladek i'm talking to you
from
the other side of the globe i'm in
israel actually it's
3 40 a.m here well
i guess you already heard enough jokes
about being gentle
without leaving your home
anyway my cats just gave me that look of
you know
what's wrong with you human like even
even they love to join the
party at this time of day but they're
like no no for us
anyway uh it's such an honor and
pleasure for me to be
back at ndc sydney conference
the last time i s in the sea
sydney it was two years ago it was in
person conference
back then
i experienced of using the dreaming
design and some of the mistakes
we did at that and
what we had learned from that ex now
this session today
is going to follow the same scheme but
today i'm going to talk about
event driven architecture
i began a few words about myself i work
in our industry for
over 20 years now
almost half of these years i
am working in various architecture
related roles
and i really love software architecture
i am
really fascinated by the topic of
software design
i i tend to disagree
a lot of opinions i prefer to ask
uncomfortable questions
and look you know into the essence of
the things why different practices
are there problems they're supposed to
solve and
what are the context in which each a
pattern or each solution should be
applied
and i want to talk about
today the event
german architecture
now this whole topic of event driven
architecture
and specifically the event event pattern
actually way too common nowadays you
know
the events they're like everywhere
nowadays
we have event driven architecture we
have event sourcing
and of course we have microservices but
they are calling for integrating
microservices
asynchronously through events as the
default unit
however this popularity came with
many avenge an architecture and
comment the magic sauce as if you can
take a monolith
pour some events over it
let's do my dream in design and of
course ever
of course that's not true this is not
how not how things work
this pattern is not some kind
but it's just a tool and as any tool
it can be used to create some great
stuff but it
also has a dark side you're going to pay
a hell of a price for misusing or
abusing it
now i have experience of doing both
misusing and using it
in the next 40 minutes i want to share
with you some stories about the troubles
i got myself into by misusing the driven
architecture
how we got got ourselves out of those
troubles
and what i had learned a the hard way
from
that experience now the stories i'm
going to share with you
are based on my experience working for a
company called in your nose
fortunately for all of us that company
doesn't exist anymore which means i am
free to say whatever i want
so event an architecture i want to start
with
some basics i want to make sure that all
of us agree on
what is architecture what are the goals
of software architecture
what are events and how does
event driven architecture works what are
the requirements for
that architectural pattern to be
implemented
correctly now i will start with some
theory
and the horror stories i'm going to
share later
are going to be based happily on this
theoretical part
and i want to start actually you know by
asking
you a question what is software
architecture
and here on the slack channel it is
open here in front of me and i'd love to
hear your opinion
what is software architecture
come on people don't be shy i'm gonna do
all the talking have
your opinions
well in the meantime while your answers
are coming
in turmoil so
when we're pondering this question
usually this quote comes to mind
oh actually i'm seeing answers here in
the chat
of webex let's open the chat
a system level design that specifies how
different parts of the system interact
awesome
that's a great insight yeah oh
if you have more opinions feel free to
share them
and also anyway i'm going to run through
a lot of material in the next few
minutes
so if you have any questions if
something is not clear
just ask your questions don't wait till
the end
i'm from israel we're used to
interrupting each other
all the time so that's okay oh diagram
boxes with errors yeah i love that
answer
model of the code high level choices
made that have large effect on the
technical development of the system cool
yeah we're going to talk about that
aspect as well
okay so we have this quote right here
architecture is about
the important stuff whatever that is
now i doubt someone would argue that
server software architecture is not
important right
you know robust
software architecture is crucial for the
success not only of
the software but in many cases
of the whole organization that the
software system
is supposed to serve for example at my
previous workplace at that company in
chennai's when we just started we had to
make
many architectural decisions for example
whether
we should use the self-managed servers
or go to the cloud and i'm talking to
you about it
it was about over 10 years ago so back
then
that question wasn't triggered we also
had to decide
which databases to choose languages
frameworks etc etc
and of course we had to align the
systems architecture
with this business domain which was by
itself
quite public for us back then now
all these decisions were hard and risky
a correct decision would move the
business forward
while a wrong decision a system
way harder to implement and to maintain
both in the short and the long term
so architectural decisions are
not only important but they are also
hard and complex
therefore in my opinion the of software
architecture
is to manage of a system
and usually we manage this complexity
as you said here in the chat by
decomposing systems
into sets of interconnected components
modules these modules they can appear at
different levels they can be
methods classes namespaces services and
even whole
systems but at whatever level they
are the underlying idea in the
underlying principles
are still the same proper modules
make it easier to reason about the
system as a whole
and about each of its components
individually
now just a second i want to open the
chat window it
closed for some reason for me
okay sorry so on the architectural level
modularity reduces risk of the design
design decisions we are making you know
it limits
this code oh sorry
what's going on here my second device is
okay yeah cool so on the architectural
level modularity reduces risk of the
design decisions
we are making to the scope of a specific
module for example let's say we have a
component which
uses a relational database
well if for some reason one day we
decide
database doesn't work anymore well
we refactor it work with a document
store and
that change is going to affect that
component
itself and not the whole system
now another way to put it modularity
allows us to divide the complexity of
the system
into two types the first type is
low complexity and
local com is the complexity of
a single component and the easiest way
to evaluate it
or you know to just explain this concept
is
first of all you know asking yourself
if you were to introduce a junior team
member
and you need to explain what a support a
a specific model is in charge of
how hard or how easy would it be to
to explain the
what that model where what module is
doing
so for example in our system in china
was we had a commission's module
all of its public api methods were a
coherent set of act
related to calculations of commissions
on the other hand we had another much
larger module that was in charge of
managing advertising campaigns
creative material and even
managing contracts with third-party
companies
now the first one the first module
obviously has
low local complexity and the second one
has much higher local complexity it
would
take definitely a while for someone to
comprehend what what was going on inside
of such
big module and you know
at some point of time even i had no clue
what was going on there
let alone junior team members
the type of system's complexity is
global complexity and this one is
defined by the level of
interconnectedness between the system's
components
you know with low heatedness it is
easier to understand
what role each component plays in
the system it's also easier to
evolve the system's components things
since the modifications in one module
will have lower impact on the rest of
the system
here on this slide you can see an
example of a system with
let's say relatively low global
complexity
now we cannot give an objective screen
of given
integer value of how good or bad that
architecture is
or how complex how high its global
complexity
but you know we can compare this diagram
here we have many more connections
this system is much more interconnected
as if we compared to the previous one
this one had
a much higher global complexity
these components are much more coupled
to each other
and again the overall system is way
more interconnected and coupled
injuries reduce complexity of the system
and make it the system more adaptable to
future requirements
and changes and that makes the process
of defining boundaries
a key architectural decision
so if the question of
what is software architecture in my
opinion
ruth milan gave a crystal clear answer
she said that system design is
inherently about boundaries
what's in what's out what spans and what
moves between it reshapes what is
outside just as it shapes this side
system design is about turning
boundaries
between components
and speaking about what moves between
those
boundaries of different of
this pattern we often use for decap
events and the idea behind this
pattern it's actually fairly simple you
know
an event is a message which is used as a
contract for
integrating systems usually that's what
a typical event looks like
it has some metadata and the payload
which carries
the message itself now
according to the contents of that
payload
we can categorize events into three
types
and i took this these definitions from
martin fowler's article
uh what do you mean by event driven
so the first type of events is
what martin calls event notification
and such event is used to notify that
something
important has happened but it contains
minimal
information the nature of that change
a subscriber needs more data
it can explicitly create the source
system for
further information
in a sense event notification is like
this
weird thing right here by the way does
anybody
here doesn't know what
the thing is
i'm looking at the chat now
yes that's pager that's what slack
looked like in the last century
so yeah how how pleasure how pagers used
to work you would receive this message
which
say that hey some stuff on
but you have to call the number on the
message to get
the detailed information that's the idea
of
event notification the system
communicates that something has happened
but
if other components need more
information they have to query
explicitly for that
this the next type
color calls event caret state transfer
and here the source system uses events
to notify its subscribers
about changes in that system's internal
state it's
data and this kind of events
can come in two forms it can be either
a click snapshot modified entity
or the message can specify only the
fields that were actually changed
so for example if you have a module
which
uh which manages customers and each
customer records
has i know hundreds of and only one of
them
was changed well you don't want to dump
the whole structure
on the message box so you can optimize
that
by only transmitting what has the field
actually changed because of some
operation
in any way all the data published by
such event events is sufficient for the
subscribers
for the subscribers to hold a local
cache and to work with it
they don't have to query the publisher
for any additional
details as in the case of event
notification
and the final type is the events used in
do management design
or for event sourcing usually we call
them
domain events such events are
somewhere between the previous two types
as notification events they notified
that something
important has happened but they also
carry enough data to describe
what has actually happened
this data however it should be modeled
as
close as possible to the business domain
and not some particular state
representation
as in the case of events for carrying
changes
in state variant duncan jones
says here the main event should be
stateless as regards
the entity to which event occurred in
other words
money deposit event holds no
data on the account balance in this case
account buttons that would be a state
you know
status representation of the account at
this
point of time a domain event on the
other hand
describes what has happened in the
business domain
money was deposited and with that
we want to transmit all the related
information for example
from which account the money
was deposited the destination of course
the amount of money
timestamp etc whatever we need
whatever we we can we can add that
describes that specific
business event so
these are the three types of events
again notification event only signals
that something has happened
event carried state transfer is
basically data
a data replication mechanism which
which is performed through events and
finally
domain events are somewhere in between
between a notification events and event
period state transfer
and you know to demonstrate these
differences furthermore
i love this example you can see on the
slide here actually i borrowed it from
my friend
or a gauzy and she uses the following
example to
er to demonstrate the differences so
a notification event would be a marriage
well
we're just waiting that's a marriage
what has happened but
we are not carrying not any other
information about
who married whom and any other related
data event state transfer
will say hey we have this person
and from now on this person has a new
last name
well maybe we would add a you know
a miracle stat status as well as a field
because it was changed as well
but that's it we are not describing the
details about
the specific business event
domain event on the other hand would
look like you know that memory
and we have the idea of the person the
partner id
and we have other a other information
related to that event for example
the person assumed a their partner's
last name
true false that would be a domain event
now it's crucial to choose the correct
event type
for specific tasks otherwise
instead of a modern architecture you
will end up with
accidental complexities and even the
dreaded
distributed monolith and to demonstrate
it
i want to share some stories of of
war and horror from my experience at
that company
inner novus now
before i do i want to briefly describe
the business domain of that company so
that it would be easier for you to know
to understand the systems that we were
building so
at internals our goal was to allow
companies that
produce products or services to
outsource
their marketing related chores like
creative materials for them would
publish advertising campaigns
optimize them collect leads coming
coming from these campaigns and
eventually
our own sales agents would make the
calls and sell
our customers products
pretty complex and wide business domain
and that usually happens initially we
try to implement this
whole system as one big
monolith classes
wise you know the system had the very
low global complexity
we only have one component
that's probably the minimal global
complexity possible
however this this component's
local complexity was huge
but everything was implemented in it all
that business logic
so unsurprisingly after some time
this design started breaking under its
own weight
it became slow hard to test and overall
unpredictable so we decided to break the
monolith into two subsystems marking
crm that's what it looked like
marketing system was in charge of
collecting and publishing
marketing events for example
clicks submitted leads etc and
it was kind of stupid it didn't really
do
anything with those events apart from
and publishing them to the subscribers
those subscribers on the other hand they
were
free to do whatever they want with those
events
however as time passed we noticed that
display this despite that
all those subscribers were doing
exactly the same thing they transformed
those
marketing events into exactly the same
state representation now
it's important to point out that this
wasn't a mere projection
that just transformed the incoming data
now
it calculated different business metrics
for
each event for example
is this event coming from any lead
or is this an existing customer that
already
purchased one of the products and
there were many such calculations
and not only that some of them were
really complex
but they also had to change frequently
they were highly volatile
and when that business logic had to
change it had to change simultaneously
across
all of those subscribers now of course
that introduced a very strong coupling
between
all those systems
in addition we were quickly hit in the
face by
unreliability of the network here on the
left side of this diagram
because we never assumed that these
events
are going to be delivered exactly in the
same order
as they were published and we also
believe that they will be delivered
exactly once
as if this whole system
acts as one big logical
transaction as you may guess
that wasn't always the case at the
moment things didn't go as planned
the same events produced different
results
for different subscribers now
this we had to employ some
infrastructure
which in tank entangled these components
even
more bottom line the global complexity
of that
system skyrocketed
we solve this by refactoring that
marketing system into an event
sourced a system
that new implementation would
encapsulate all that complex and
volatile business logic
instead of publishing mere notification
events you remember
the first pages it emitted more
elaborate
domain events that described what
has actually happened in the business
domain
and this refactoring lowered both the
global complexity of the whole
system and the local complexities of its
components because now we were making
all those decisions in one place
instead of duplicating them in bi
crm and all other subscribers
now speaking about that crm system on
the right here
originally we implemented it in a
traditional way
you know it stored its data in a
relational database
however after some time we understood
that
this implementation has been limiting us
in
multiple ways first it didn't scale
second the relational model limited the
insights we were able to get from that
data
some business stakeholders needed more
flexible way
of looking at that information
therefore we decided to refactor the crm
into an event sourcing and
cqrs based system
that's what our initial implementation
of securist
looked like it was pretty much
the client would submit a command its
execution would result
in new domain events appended to the
event store
and these domain events were used to
project
view models finally the commands
result was communicated from the read
model
back to the user those were
the so-called one-way commands
but the thing is there are no commands
here
you know those are just events
creating s commands and systems
of the command and of course of course
it has to communicate back to the user
the reason why
it's used was there a technical issue
or that command was invalid
and if it wasn't valid why how the
consumer can
fix it so in our in our case
because we tried to follow the
those one-way commands the system's user
experience
was terrible it was terrible because of
this
very long feedback loop so
to fix this when you factor the commands
to be
executed synchronously and
not only synchronously but the commands
return their execution result directly
to the user
the user didn't have to pull the
projections for the
updated view models it was immediately
returned
synchronously and this changed
dramatically improved the user
experience of the whole systems
of the whole system sorry the users were
getting the results of that
immediately and again
if a sales agent modified a customer
okay exit command
they would receive the result of their
action immediately
now the only limitation we had to follow
here is that
the data returned as a command result
should come over strongly consistent
storage the event store in this case
but because projections they are
eventually consistent and of course we
cannot
trust that they are going to be updated
immediately
therefore if you need to return any
information
to the caller of a command and that
is stored is available in a strongly
consistent storage
go ahead you can just return it there is
no need to go through that
long feedback loop again
the change contributed to a much better
user experience
now let's talk more about those
projections
the crm system published those domain
events
as its public api and expected
other systems to leverage that freedom
of generating their own
projections and at the beginning it
looked
awesome you know especially when when we
compare this to the initial relational
database based
design however after our
secures honeymoon period was over
we realized that again ninety percent
of these subscribers
exactly the same models and again
as in the case of the marketing system
this
introduced logical coupling the logic
that
projected events into a workable state
was
duplicated in all those subscribing
components
and not only was it duplicated
but it held the knowledge each
domain event affects the state it will
tightly couple to the crms
implementation details
crm exposed many
different types of events and
all those subscribers had to closely
follow the changes in the crms
implementation first the server package
often and if a new event type was
introduced
the subscribers had to reflect let
change
as fast as possible because
well if a new event that was introduced
in this crm can affect the value
of some projected fields here ignoring
the
event would lead to inconsistent
state to sum it up
if we were to evaluate this architecture
well it almost screams at us high global
complexity
and with it so to
pull this mass we encapsulated that
projection logic in the crm system
itself
instead of exposing hundreds of domain
events
it published changes to the projected
state
through event grid state transfer
so basically before speaking about those
three types of events
we went from integrating through domain
events to integrating through event
period state transfer
effectively that exchange has compressed
the serums public api
and its implementation details those
numerous domain events
into a much more restricted set of
public events
topic events that just describe the
changes
in the state they were optimized for
integrations with other systems
now of course that change did raise the
local complexity of the crm system
but it wasn't a big deal you know that
change dramatically reduced the global
complexity
of the whole system it didn't move
all the coupling we had here between
these
components
the next story is about a betrayal
so we had this nice micro services based
system
in low global complexity and
actually low local complexities of
the cells but then because of some new
requirements we had
introduced a new miner
it processed data from all other
services
and communicated back some of its
decisions this solution looked
i don't it looked okay initially but
behind the scenes what really happened
here
is that this new service
ended up being an architectural trojan
horse
it introduced lots of implementation
coupling and because of that the global
complexity of that
system went through the roof
the solution was to use the jimmy
designs
and a corruption layer pattern that
pattern
sees a two systems
which are innovating with each other and
it acts as an adapter it
translates the integration model
used by the original systems into a
different model which is
for the integration needs and that's
what we did here that and and
per option layer in the middle it
separated the integration complexity
between these services it separated from
the business complexity
of the new service we had to introduce
here
it was kind of complex has very complex
business logic
now ac acl's local complexity was
really low again all it had to do is to
aggregate data
transform it into a different model and
communicate
back to the message bus
but this more complex service and that
ended up encapsulating the complexity of
the business domain
and coupled so much to the rest of the
system anymore
its implementation had to change
frequently but
now it had much lower effect on the rest
of the system
in other words by introducing this
thin translating service with really low
global complexity
we reduced the story with really low
local complexity where it used the
global complexity of
the whole system
this verb the next system started pretty
similarly to the previous one
actually it was our first step at
implementing a microservices-based
system and back then you know we've
heard about the success stories of
different companies using microservices
and that microservices hype was just
starting
it was like hey micro services
that probably means that
something should be small cool so
the smaller the service is going to be
the better the
overall architecture that was our
and let's see what results we got from
from implementing this naive logic
so we designed those services thinking
that the smaller the service
the better and of course we integrating
them
mainly asynchronously through publishing
and subscribing to the main events
and initially this design did produce
low
global complexity of the system and low
local complexities of the components
however over time this service has
become more and more chatting
we started adding more and more
connections
between them until at this point almost
all of them needed data from all other
services
provide the required data we tried
putting even more of that magic sauce
you know adding more and more events
but as you can see here in this diagram
the global complexity of that system
skyrocketed
we ended up with a distributed monolith
and the abuse of the events was just a
symptom here of the real problem
sorry the real problem
is invalid decomposition of the system
into modules
the solution course was to merge some of
those services
together in such a way that would lower
the global complexity of the system
and as a result lower the number of
events we had to transmit between the
services
in order for the whole system to work
now the last story and i cannot
trash talk too much here because
i wasn't involved directly in this
presentation so even though
i have lots of emotions
talking about it i'll try and
consider my words here so
about three or four years ago
internationals was merged with another
company
and here what i stumbled upon when we
did architectural reviews
that system would process mans from
its users write some changes to a
relational database
and events to
a message bus the goal of using the
events here was to build a scalable
distributed system now
please help me out in this chat right
here
do you see any problems with this design
yes yes katie and michelle
you're both right there's no guarantee
that
these events are going to be delivered
if they did
if the database or the second
of the or the message bus ride fails
that what i call transaction coupling
transaction coupling between the
database and the message bus
another word is some kind of
distributed transaction that should have
been
implemented as you've said here in the
chat
what's going to happen if that process
that system
will if it's going to die in the middle
just
after committing the database
transaction but before publishing
messages well the user is going to get
another
error some of the data is going to be
written
to the database and some of it is going
to be lost
because those events are not going to be
published
online data corruption the system is
going to end up in an
incorrect state
also for all those subscribers here
the order of the events was important
but it wasn't enforced by the producer
and that's a different type of coupling
that's called temporal coupling
when these subscribers
they have to be called in a specific
order
now let's see what the subscribers were
doing with these events
so the first one that backup db here it
was simple
just recall recorded all the messages in
the persistent storage
you know as you know storage mechanism
for
events the second subscriber
connected a state representation of the
business entity
and it's stored it in an in-memory
database
as a cache
subscriber it forwarded
advanced to bi for analysis
but first it enriched all income
events with the state produced here
in that cash state in the previous
subscriber now effectively
again these two subscribers are
temporarily coupled to each other
they should be executed in a specific
order or otherwise
you know the analysis model which is
going to be communicated from
the subscriber right here is going to be
enriched with
inconsistent data now of course
such orchestration of a distributed
system is not
trivial and in case it just
ended up corrupting our production data
now of course the simplest solution to
most of the problems here
is the outbox pattern you know leverage
the relational database
which was already there
and you know we all we did is we
expanded that
original database transaction
in addition meeting the state changes to
writing the outgoing events
into an outbox table
and then we used a relay to pick up
those
events from that new table and
asynchronously
to the message bus that element
all that transactional coupling also
by writing those events into the same
table
it was much easier for us to
keep track of the events the order in
which
they were written and to check whether
events are coming out of work in the
subscribers
as for temporal coupling we had here
in these two components well that was a
result of
bad service boundaries what we did is
we changed that second er
to publish event carried state transfer
events
with changes in the state of
any of the data that were projected in
that service and those events
were submitted to a to the pi systems
so these were the war stories i wanted
to share
now let's see what we had learned from
that experience and
when designing event-driven systems be
pessimistic about it you know
don't even assume that things must work
no things will fail and believe me
things are going to fail the most on
weekends i tested that assumption
it was correct
that optimistic consistency
i show you here is nothing but
eventual data corruption and that two
event driven architecture it contains
the word
driven for a reason your whole system
depends on the delivery
of its events so make sure that
the events are delivered consistently
no matter what happens next
identify your private and public events
some events are implementation details
especially domain events in advancers
you might be tempting to expose them as
public
interface as a part of your public
interface
but you do not want external systems
to depend on your implementation details
right
you want to be able to change those
implementation
details without breaking the
integrations
of the whole system in other words
in other words if you are going to
expose your implementation details
through the boundaries of the services
you you're going to end up with
people and implementation top links
so instead leverage both private and
public events private private events
they can be very different domain events
and you can have many of them however
when designing your public apis
the boundaries of your components
compress those
private into a more restricted set of
public events
this public event should be modeled with
integrated
integration needs in mind they should be
optimized
for integration your overarching goal
here
is to reduce global complexity of the
whole system
and you can definitely do it by using
both
private and public events and making
sure that
your public events are as compressed as
possible
also we saw that there are types of
events
use them all now notification events and
every
event carry stage transfer are great for
integrating services
and finally instead of blind blindly
integrating microservices a
synchronously through events evaluate
their consistency requirements
if you've got services that can settle
for eventual consistency
awesome integrate them asynchronously
through
events probably using event carrier
state transfer
however if one of the components
expects to read the last right of the
second component
you have two options here first is
to integrate them through a simple
synchronous
call to get the most up-to-date data if
however
you need push-based integration then
that source service can raise a
notification event
and the subscribers subscribers will
react by getting the more detailed
information through an explicit sequence
call you know that pager pattern
if on the other hand both services share
a set of methods
that assume concurrent control or
in other words one method can be
executed at the same time
stop right there that's transaction
coupling
it will probably be safer to merge those
components
into one a into a single component
so these are the three lessons that i
wanted to share
and that time to wrap it all up
so quick summary we spoke about
event-driven architecture we spoke about
what is architecture what are events and
what makes
event-driven architecture work so
our goal is to manage complexity of the
systems
of the systems that we are designing and
we can do it through modularity
by dividing systems into components we
actually dividing
dividing the complexity into local
complexity which is on the
global complexity the interconnectedness
between the systems
components we saw that there are three
types of events
notification event which says that
something interesting has happened
event carries state transfer for
publishing changes
in data we can say that that's
a way of a replication through events
and events main events
are events that something interesting
has happened
in the business domain the
three lessons and that
in my opinion summarize our experience
with all those troubles that we got
ourselves
into by doing a benjamin architecture on
first be pessimistic use both
private and public events to compress
boundaries of your components
and to reduce the global complexity of
the whole system
and finally evaluate
because if you violate your consistency
requirements by choosing an
incorrect type of event you're going to
end up with
a lot of pain and then
that's what i wanted to share a small
shameless plug
about a year ago i wrote this book it's
called what is domage dreaming design
it's a guide to this methodology that
you can
read over a well
i i was used to introduce it as a book
you can read on a flight but
it's irrelevant nowadays so i don't know
you can read it in an hour or
an hour it's a really short book
about domain driven design another book
project i participated in
is domain german design the first 15
years
and i shared our experience of using
domain driven design
in that company in internals
currently i'm on
another book i cannot share any details
but you can follow me on twitter or read
my blog
to get more details about it and all i
can say is
the new book is going to be closely
related to the subject of this
discussion
you